haley mayuna says israel considers her
existence a threat just because she's a
palestinian a refugee who was forced out
of her home in 1948 now she's threatened
to be evicted again
she's been living in this cave in
masaforyata in the southern hebron hills
for decades
the 80 year old gave birth to her
children here in the very same cave and
tells us she doesn't want to be buried
anywhere
else suffering is not over as long as we
are here they are brutalizing us if they
just leave us and let us be we'd have a
good life
halimah grew up witnessing shrinking
palestinian lands and moral israeli
settlements locals here have recently
lost a 20-year legal battle to allow
them to stay
they had little hope in israeli justice
like many other palestinians they
believe israel's supreme court is part
of whitewashing the occupation
for decades israel has been using
different methods to strip palestinians
out of their lands closed military areas
weapons ranges natural reserves and
state lands are all but some ways to
push palestinians out at the same time
israeli settlements considered illegal
under international law are expanding on
those very same lands every year
palestinians mark nakba which means
catastrophe in arabic that's when more
than 700 000 people were forced out of
their homes by the creation of israel
74 years on many here say that nakba
isn't just a memory but a reality with
israeli land grabs evictions and illegal
settlement expansion they want the world
to know that nakba is continuing every
day
those who left their homes thinking
they'll be back within days have had
their children and grandchildren born in
refugee camps refugees in palestine and
the diaspora exceed six million people
around ten thousand refugees live in the
phawa refugee camp near hapron city
south of the occupied west bank
since its establishment in 1948 its
population has tripled
ahmad ranati usually volunteers to
organize fun activities with children
while he teaches them songs about return
he does not think it's possible in his
lifetime
i've lost hope
not that i don't want to return but the
situation and what they have planned for
us suggests that it's over we've lost
our lands they sold us out
as time passes the waiting goes on and
palestinians now are even struggling to
stay on the little land that is left
accountability is the main word here
people have come and they say that they
want justice for shireen and for all the
other israeli crimes people here say
they have no doubt that israel killed
shireen they say that israel is not only
targeting palestinians but also
journalists who are spreading the word
out
about what's happening to palestinians
who have been living under a military
occupation for decades